in this video we're going to do an
example that gives us a little bit of
practice to think about what does it
mean to divide by a fraction so if we
want to figure out what eight divided by
seven-fifths is but we're going to break
it down into two steps
first of all we're going to use these
visuals here to think about how many
groups of seven fifths are in one or
another way of thinking about it is how
many seven fifths are in a whole so
pause this video and just think about
this first part
all right so let's look at seven-fifths
seven-fifths is everything from here all
the way
to there
and then one is this
so how many seven-fifths are in one well
you can see that one which is the same
thing as five-fifths is less than
seven-fifths so it's actually going to
be a fraction of a seven-fifth that is
one or that is in one and you can see
what that fraction is
one is what fraction of seven-fifths
well if you look at the fifths
seven-fifths is of course seven of them
and a whole is five-fifths so five
of the seven-fifths make a whole so the
answer right over here is five
sevenths
five sevenths of a seven-fifths is equal
to one you can also see this right over
here if you take each of these to be a
fifth
each of these
to be a fifth
then this whole bar is equal to seven
fifths
and the blue part is equal to one so how
many seven-fifths are in the blue part
well we can see it's 5 7 of the whole
bar once again 5 7 of the whole bar so
we can also think about this as 1
divided by
7 fifths this is another way of saying
how many seven-fifths are in one or how
many groups of seven-fifths are on one
and this is equal to five-sevenths
which we've learned in other videos is
the reciprocal of seven-fifths the
numerator and the denominator are is
swapped
so now what is eight divided by
seven-fifths going to be
well if one divided by seven-fifths is
five-sevenths or if you have
five-sevenths of a seven-fifths of a
seven fifths in one i know the word
language gets a little bit confusing
well you're going to have eight times
that many in eight
so this is going to be the same thing as
eight
times
we could do it this way eight times one
divided by
seven fifths
or you could just view this as eight
times the reciprocal of seven fifths
which is five
over seven and we've learned how to
multiply this before
8 times 5 7 is going to be equal to 40
7.
and we're done you could obviously also
write that as a mixed number if you like
this would be the same thing
as 5 and
5 7. so the big picture is when we think
about how many of a fraction are in one
that's the same thing as saying what's
one divided by that fraction as you see
visually here you essentially get the
reciprocal of that fraction and so if
you take any other number other than one
divided by that fraction you're
essentially just going to multiply it by
that reciprocal because it's that number
times one so when you divide by that
fraction it's that number times the
reciprocal